مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
اسرائيل
على حدود سوريا والعراق
ارتفاعه نسبه المصانع السعوديه الملتزمه
بتطبيق التصاريح البيئيه الى 77 في المئه
خلال العام الجاري
في الرابعه ايضا
في مونديال قطر الجماهير العربيه تتوافدوا
لمسانده اسود الاطلس لتخطي ديوك فرنسا
حامله اللقب
ودار الاوبرا السلطانيه في مسقط تحتفل
بعقدها الاول الرابعه في جوله خاص على
ابرز معالمها
البدايه من الاحتجاجات في ايران التي تمهد
الاجهزه الامنيه والمحاكم الثوريه فيها
لاصدار احكام القاسيه ضد عدد من الرياضيين
والفنانين الذين اعتقلوا خلال الاحتجاجات
الاخيره في مدينه شيراز بتهمه تشكيله
ايضا اشراق ابادي مدربه ركوب الدراجات
بالاضافه الى محمد خير وهو مدرب تسلق جبال
ونسب التقرير عددا من الادوار اليهم بناء
على اعترافاتهم القيصريه بينها مسؤوليه
اختيار او اختبار التفجيرات وصنع العبوات
الناسف ماشي
تقرير مراسلنا بلا حدود الثانويه انضمام
ايران الى القائمه القادمه في سجن
الصحفيين بعد ما اعتقل النظام الايراني
عددا غير مسبوقا من الصحافيين الذين
يواجهون حاليا خطر عقوبه الاعدام
[موسيقى]
وقد تزايد والتجهود الدوليه لمنع تنفيذ
احكام الاعدام بحق المتظاهرين التزامنا مع
زياده اصدار السلطات الايرانيه هذه
الاحكام واحتمال التنفيذ الوشيك لبعضها
[موسيقى]
فيديوهات هنا من الرياض البحر حميد سيد
صالح اهلا وسهلا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
يعني ما الذي يمكن استنتاجه اولا من
استمرار النظام الايراني في عمليات
الاعدام العالميه رغم كل الضغوط الدوليه
حتى الان بالاضافه الى ازدياد حاله الغضب
عند شارع الايراني
والخوف وسياسه التي يتبعها النظام منذ
عقود في الواقع يعني الامر الثاني هو اا
انه يريد طمئنه القوات الامنيه او مليشيات
البسي يجب ان من يتعرض لهم لن يبقى دون
عقاب ولذلك نرى هذه المحاكمات السريعه
وغير القانون التي تفتقر الى ابسط معايير
المحاكمات العادله حتى اوفي القوانين
الايرانيه نفسها وهذا ما يتحدث بالكثير من
المحامين والحقوقين فالهذه المحاكمه
اهدافها سياسيه وامنيه وليست همم يعني
تحقيق او تطبيق العداله كما تدعي السلطات
لذلك همم نرى يعني اولا المحاكمات
سوريه بدون وجود محامين همم ايضا هي بدات
من المدن الكبرى من طهران اعدام محسن
شكاري ثم في مشهد همم ثاني اكبر مدينه
والان في شيراز همم يبدو انه يتم التحضير
لتوجيه احكام الاعدام لمجموعه جديده همم
كل هذه همم العمليات تهدف الى شيء واحد
وبث الرعب الخوف لكن لحد الان النتائج
كلها كانت عكسيه فكل ما يعدم النظام عدد
اكبر من الناشطين تخرج جماهير بشكل اكبر
وهمم تمدد وتستمر بالاحتجاجات
ويعني همم بدات هذه الاصوات تاخذ بعدا
دوليا نرى يعني اليوم همم هناك ايضا تصويت
مرتقى في الامم المتحده همم لطرد
من لجنه المراه في قبلها كانت يعني تشكيل
لجنه حقائق ولا تزال ايران تقاوم لا تريد
التعاون معها لكي لا تنكشف ابعاد هذه
الجرائم التي ترتكف في داخل وخاصه في
السجون والمعتقلات وما راي الرساله التي
ايضا يودي النظام توجها اليوم في هذا
التوقيت من وراء الروايه التي قدمها حول
يعني تنفيذ الاحكام العذاب بحق الرياضيين
مثقفين ايضا
بتهمه اشعه الفوضى ونوايا تفجيرات ايضا
هذا سببه في الواقع
مشاركه عدد كبير من الفنانين والرياضيين
بتاييد الاحتجاجات يعني من النداء الى علي
كريم الى لعب كره القدم الى ممثلين الى
مشاهير السينما كلهم دعموا هذه الاحتجاجات
ودعوه الى وقف القمع
يبدو ان النظام يريد من خلال محاكمه هذه
الشريحه تخويف
بهم يعني لذلك هذا ثبت سيناريو مع هدى
استخبارات الحرس الثوري تعتقل مجموعه
وتفرض عليهم سيناري وتنتزع الاعترافات تحت
التعذيب ثم تظهرها على التلفزيون همم
تحضيرا وتمهيدا لادانتهم بالحراره مثل هذه
الروايات هل هي مؤثره في الشارع لايراني
يعني هل هناك ما زالت حالا من الانقسام
تجاه النظري الى مثل هذه الحالات وحالات
الاعدام تحديدا داخل المجتمع بين مؤيد
ومعارض
همم النظام وهذه الاجهزه تريد ان تقول
انها همم تسيطر الاحتجاجات وتعتقل
الفاعلين وخاصه رؤوس المجموعات كما تسميهم
وفي الواقع يعني حتى لو كانت هذه
الاعترافات همم القسريه لم تؤدي الى شيء
همم هي بالتالي اا يعني اداه بايد هذه
الاجهزه التي تقول لمرئ فيها انهم سيطره
احتجاجات لكن الحقيقه يعني هذه المحاكمه
سوره فشلت على مدى عقود لانه الكثير من
المعتقلين بعد سنوات يخرجون ويفضحون
النظام همم تتم تبريئتهم في الحقيقه لانه
لم يرتكبه اي شيء مثل ما حدث في قضايا
العلماء النوويين مثلا فهذه ايضا احداث
مشابهه همم الهدف الاساسي هو تطبيق
سيناريو التي ترسمه اجهزه الامن
والاستخبارات الايرانيه لكي تحاول ربط هذه
الاحتجاجات بالخارج وعلى انها مؤامره
وعمليها تقريبا وليس احتياجات مؤشرات حتى
الان على نجاح النظام الايراني في هذه
السياسه سواء بالترهيب لا تباطؤ في هذه
الاحتجاجات سياسه الاضرابات كذلك والدعوات
الاحتجاجات واستمرارها مستمر لكن الى اي
مدى يمكن ان يصل الشعب الايراني في تعطيل
مع استمرار هذه السياسه من الاعدامات
القمه الترهيب
وهل هناك شعور بالفعل اليوم على مستوى
الداخله على الخارجي لانه هناك حاله نبذ
للنظام على مستوى الداخلي قد تؤدي الى ما
هو اخطر خلال يومين القادم بالطبع يعني
اولا الشعراء همم مستمره وبعد ايام يعني
تكمل شهر ثالث وتدخل في شهر الرابع وهذا
يحتاج دجاجات غير مسبوقه عمليات الاعدام
والقمع لم تؤثر همم السيناريوهات همم
متعدده الحقيقه اولها ان النظام همم
سيستطيع كما قنعها كما قمع احتجاجات 2019
من خلال قتل 1,500 متظاهر الاحتجاجات
لسبقتها ولكن الان نرى ان حتى هذه همم
اعمال القتل والقمر الاعتقالات لم تستطع
ايقاف الانتفاضه سيناريو ثاني هو ان يدفع
النظام هذه الاحتجاجات نحو العنف باستفاد
من التجربه السوريه التي طبقها هو الحرس
الثوري مع النظام السوري او في العراق
تنفيدا لقمعها وعسكرتها لانه الاقوى في
هذا المجله لكن السيناري الثالث هو انه
الان الناس ماتوا يدركون ان الغطاء الذي
كان همم الغطاء المقصود تعامل دول الغرب
سياسه المهادنه والاسترضاء لنظام لم تعد
موجوده هذا في الحقيقه عام الاخر اضافي
لا توجد خطوات متقدمه في اغلاق السفارات
سفراء وغيرها وهي الخطوه المطلوبه الان
همم الايراني صحيح لكن الموقف المختلف هو
انه في السابق كانت تدخلات لصالح النظام
كان مرتاحا بانه لا توجد الان الوضع مختلف
هناك تشكيل لجنه حقائق قرارات جديده
المزيد من العقوبات المزيد من الضغوط
اعتقد مع استمرار الاحتجاجات في الداخل
وايصال صوت الايراني الخارجي ستزيد هذه
الضغوط ما ستعطي زخما كبيرا لهذه شكرا
جزيلا لك البحث في الشارع الايراني صالح
حميد
اكيد رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيليه افيكو
خافي استهداف قافله يسريحه ايرانيه على
حدود سوريا والعراق قبل السابقه كما قال
انه جرت تشويش تماما على مشروع ايران بوضع
المئات من الصواريخ ارض جو في سوريا
ولبنان اشار الى ان هناك رؤيه ايرانيه
كانت تصبوا الى انشائي حزب الله جديد في
جنوبي هضبه الجولان هذه الرؤيه كانت تتمثل
بالمئات من الصواريخ وعشرات الالاف من
الميليشيات
واكداك خافيه الجيش الاسرائيلي منع نحو
اربع مئه في العام الحالي بمساعده جهاز
المخابرات العامه وحرس الحدود
يخنه الولد ده
الهجوم على قافله الشاحنات قبل اسابيع
قليله على الحدود السوريه العراقيه نفذته
اسرائيل لم نكن نعرف قبل اسابيع قليله عن
عبور القافله السوريه من العراق الى سوريا
جرى التشويش تماما على مشروع ايران بوضع
المئات من صواريخ ارض جو في سوريا ولبنان
الجيش الاسرائيلي من على نحو 400 عمليه في
العام الحالي في بعض الحالات كان يتم
اطلاق اكثر من 30 الى 40 صاروخا وفي احدى
الغارات تم اطلاق سبعين صاروخ لاتجاه
طائرتنا
قال رئيس منظمه الطاقه الاداريه الايرانيه
محمد سلامه ان مسؤولين من الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه سيزورون ايران خلال الايام
القليله المقبله في محاوله لازاله عقبه
بشان اثار يورانيوم عثر عليها في مواقع
ايرانيه غير معلن عنها
مرحله الاعمال الانشائيه للخزمه الاولى من
المشاريع الفندقيه لوجهه مسار مكه تدخل
حيز التنفي
تخيل ان تمتلك ارضا فريده تتلالا وسط
منطقه سياحيه مفعمه بالاصاله والحداثه على
طريق المدينه المنوره وطريق الملك عبد
الله الفريده بها تعلو سحابه الاستثمار
[موسيقى]
انا حسيت الاسنان مشكله شائعه مره معجون
سنسوداين المطور الجديد بيدخل لعمق السنه
يقلل من حساسيه الاسنان امسح الاشخاص انهم
ما يهملوا مشكله حساسيه الاسنان
[موسيقى]
في مزارع بالمعايير الاصح
دجاج اليوم
طازج بكل ثقه
[موسيقى]
للحين ما تلاقي اللي يحررك منه
بس هذيك اللحظه اللي بتبدا تشعر فيها انك
اخيرا بتتحرر منا هي نفس اللحظه اللي
بتشعر فيها انك رجعت لطبيعتك زي في اي يوم
طبيعي
ايش ما كان نوع المك
التحرر من الالم يبدا بباندول
لمنال على اعلى نسب تسميات بدات الان صوت
عبر تطبيق جوي اوورز لواحد من المرشحين
الاربعه من كل فئه
من مسلسلات الموسيقى الرياضه ومواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
التسجيل عبر التطبيق لتكون احد الفائزين
العشره بفرصه الفوز لتذكارتين لحضور هذا
الحدث الضخم مع ضيف من اختياره لتعيش ليله
فوق الخيال وتشاهد لحظه تكريم نجومكم
المفضلين
نتائج التصويت تعلن خلال حفل توزيع جوائز
صناع الترفيه جوي ورد بالحادي والعشرين من
يناير لعام 2023 مباشره من الرياض
فسارع بالتصويت الان لان صوتك انت هو
الحاسب
تطبيق جوي او وورد متوفر على اب ستور
وجوجل بلاي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في مكه المكرمه في غرب
السعوديه دخلت مرحله الاعمال عفوا
الانشائيه للخدمه الاولى من المشاريع
الفندقيه لمشروع وجهه مسار مكه حيث تنفيذ
بقيمه استثماريه تتجاوز سبعه مليارات ريال
تتضمن هذه المرحله انشاء سبعه ابراج
فندقيه تقع بالمنطقه المركزيه على بعد 500
متر عن ساحات الحرم المكي وتضموا مركز
تجاريا بمساحه تزيد عن 43000 متر مربع الى
جانبه محطه توقف للحافلات التردديه
اعتبر الفنانه التشكيل السعودي ضياء عزيز
مصمم مجسم بوابه مكان البدء باعمال صيانه
البوابه يعد من اهم الاحداث التي رافقته
في مسيرته منذ انشائها قبل 42 عاما
الحقيقه هي كانت فرحه التالته هذه لانه
الفرحه الاولى كانت يوم
الملك فهد الله يرحمه وافق على تنفيذها
وتنفذ فعلا
الفرحه الثانيه كانت لما الامير خالد
الفيصل الله يخليك وافق على حفر اسمي واسم
المنفذين على البوابه نفسها على اعلان
البوابه او على جسم البوابه نفسها
الفرحه الثالثه وهي اللي بعد 42 سنه تبتدي
حكايات صيانه هذه البوابه اللي كان لابد
انه يتم صيانتها والا ستدعم مع الوقت هذا
الشيء طبيعي
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
عبد الواحد الحميد عبد الواحد مرحبا بك
معي ما هي ابرز ملامح هذه المرحله المرحله
لمسارمك
نعم خالد اهلا وسهلا بك طبعا في هذا
المكان حيث وقف تحديدا يعني سوف تكون هناك
مشاريع ضخمه نتحدث عن اكثر من سبع فنادق
التي تم الاعلان عنها مؤخرا اضافه الى
مركز التجاري الضخم بمساحه التجاوز 43000
متر مربع كل هذه المشروعات ستكون هنا في
وجهه مسار همم المشروع الضخم التنموي الذي
يقام في مكه المكرمه يعني الاستثمارات في
هذا المشروع حتى الان تجاوزت اكثر من 35
مليار ريال همم اضافه الى طبعا كل ما يحدث
من اعمال انشائيه كما تشاهدهم في الصوره
هذه الاعمال الانشائيه يعني التي سوف
تحتضن كل هذه
المشروعات همم يعني تنمويه حيث يتم همم
العمل عليها على قدم وساق نشاهد في هذه
الصوره تحديدا هناك البدء بالاعمال
الانشائيه من خلال المواقف السيارات التي
انجز بعضها نتحدث عن اا عدد اكثر من 5000
و700 موقف سيارات سوف يتم انجازه خلال همم
طبعا همم الايام همم والفتره المقبله خالد
المشاريع كذلك يعني همم التي يتم العمل
عليها نتحدث حتى عن
المتاحف وحتى عن المراكز التجاريه اضافه
الى الممرات ومحطات الحافلات التي تنقل
الزوار والمعتمرين ترددايا من والى هذا
المشروع الضخم الذي يتم العمل عليه همم
كما ذكرت لك خالد الاعلان الاخير الذي همم
اعلن عنه سبع فنادق ضخمه وكبيره سوف تكون
هنا على بعد اقل من كيلو متر يعني تتحدث
عن تقريبا 500 متر عن الحرم المكي ما يعني
مكان استراتيجي ومكانهم هنا في مكه
المكرمه طيب شكرا لك من مكه المكرمه مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن
مباشره
متابعه في السعوديه ايضا كشفت هيئه المدن
الصناعيه ومناطق التقنيه عن ارتفاع نسبه
المصانع الملتزمه بتطبيق التصاريح البيئه
امم البيئيه من 25% عام 2021 الى 77% خلال
العام الجديد وذلك ضمن خطتها للحفاظ على
البيئه وتطبيقي معايير الاستدامه في المدن
الصناعيه من خلال الجولات الرقابيه وتسهيل
وصول متطلبات الانظمه البيئيه للمصانع
طيب نتابع من المدينه الصناعيه الثانيه
بالرياض مع مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز نواف
مرحبا بك حدثنا اكثر عن هذه الارقام 77 في
المئه هي نسبه المصانع الملتزمه بتطبيق
التصاريح البيئيه ما هي هذه التصاحه
نعم خالد قدره الهيئه السعوديه للمدن
الصناعيه ومناطق التقنيه برفع نسبه
المصانع او رفع نسبه الالتزام المصانع
التصاريح البيئيه الى 77% همم في هذا
العام ارتفاع كبير ويعد انجاز بيئي وانجاز
اجتماعي حقيقه نظرا لان الموظفين في المدن
الصناعيه وتحديدا هنا في المدينه الصناعيه
الثانيه في الرياض والزوار تشكل الروائح
المنبعثه من المصانع المصدر ازعاج كبير
لهم الامر الذي ايضا همم يعيق ايضا
التنميه حول المدن الصناعيه همم حتى ان
بعض الموظفين يتجنبون السكن بالقرب من
المدن الصناعيه نظرا لهذه الروائح التي
تنبعث من المصانع بشكل كبير اليوم تغير
الوضع كثيرا في الواقع همم
الالتزام المصانع الاعداد الكبيره من قبل
المصانع التي التزمت بتصاريح البيئيه
ساهمت كثيرا
تحسن البيئه والاجواء ايضا نعود اليه
المدينه دمشق في متابعه لاخر
ساذهب مباشره الى موسكو وهذه الكلمه
الوزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجيو راموس
بهذا المشروع في اقليم اخرى في العالم
وايضا هناك نشاط واسع نطاق لمنظمه شغاله
للتعاون وهذه المنظمه بال- ضعفه الى
مجموعه بريكس تعتبروا نموذج
المتعدده الاطراف
التي تحرسه على حمايته ووقايه همم قيمتها
في مختلف المجالات فان هذه همم المنظمه
تشمل ثمانيه عشر عدوان وهناك عدد من
الراغبين لتعزيز وتقويه العلاقات مع منظمه
شغلها للتعاون من قبل دول اخرى
ده ورق كتير من الجزائر
الامن الجماعيه في هذه المنطقه وحيث وعملت
على استقرار الوضع في كازاخستان في بدايه
هذا العام وكانت اثباتا لنمو ونضوج هذه
المنظمه وكذلك بالحديث عن التكامل
الاوراسي فان مبادره الصين في الطريق
الواحد وهمم
الواحد فهذا يضم عدد كبير من دول الاتحاد
الاقتصادي الاوروسي وايضا دور روسيا في
اسيا من حيث هناك شراكه قويه لروسيا بشكل
اساسي ايضا عمليه تناغم
المبادرات المختلفه التي تتمنا منطقه
اوراسيا ونحن مع ان الاقتصاد يجب ان يبقى
ذلك
كاس لبناء الهيكليه للامن العالمي واثقه
المتبادله واساسها وايضا فيه مبادره
الرئيس بوتين لتشكيل الاشارات الوراثيه
الكبيره تحت
العمليه التي تنمو ضمن اطار
المنظمه التعاون الاقتصادي الاوراسي
والاتحاد الاقتصادي الوراثي
الدول المختلفه لقارتنا الكبيره وايضا
الاهتمام الخاصه لمبادره من قبل الصين
والهند
وفي
ضمانسيه الكبيره يجري العمل على تطوير
ال
مساركم هذا الجزء من المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير
الخارجيه سرجلها بروفا من موسكو
تستضيف السعوديه ممثله بهيئه الرقابه
ومكافحه الفساد نزاهه الاجتماع الوزاريه
الاول لاجهزه انفادي قوانين مكافحه الفساد
في الدول الاعضاء بمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي
خلال الفتره من العشرين الى الحادي
والعشرين من ديسمبر الجاري
يناقش الاجتماعي مواضيع منها اقرار
اتفاقيه مكه المكرمه للتعاون بين السلطات
الفهد قوانين مكافحه الفساد للدول الاعضاء
في المنظمه بهدفي تحقيق اهداف منها فتحوا
قنوات لتبادل المعلومات والتحريات في
جرائم الفساد العابره للحدود
وقع وزير الدفاع السعوديه الامير خالد بن
سلمان مع نظيره البريطانيه
وقال وزير الدفاع السعودي في مراسم في
ساحه الخياله في لندن ان الاتفاقيه تهدف
الى التطوير قدرات وزاره الدفاع السعوديه
وتوطين الصناعات العسكريه وتعزز الشراكه
بين البلدين في المجالين العسكريين
والدفاعين من جانبيه اشاره وزير الدفاع
البريطاني الى ان اتفاق التعاون الدفاعي
مع السعوديه ركيزه هامه لمسائل الرئتين
نحو دعم الامن المشترك الاقليمي كما بحث
الجانبان التعاون الثنائي في المجال
العسكري والدفاع بالاضافه الى تطورات
الاوضاع على المستويين الاقليمي
رابعه بعد قليل
تفاعل والترقب من الجماهير العربيه
والمغربيه المسانده لاسود الاطلس في
مواجهه فرنسا
مستشفى المواساه بالخبر اول مستشفى في
القطاع الخاص يقدم خدمه استبدال مفصل
الركبه باستخدام الروبوت الجراحي من خلال
الاستفاده من خدمات الذكاء الاصطناعي رحله
علاج اقصر واسهل المواساه خبره تنبض
بالثقه
لا تتنازل ولا ترضى بشيء عادي لكن المراعي
اجود زبادي مع زبادي المراعي كالاكل الف
قيمه كل نتائج الانتخابات الاخيره بصفتك
عضو بارز في رابطه الشمال
في اوروبا بشكل عام ما السبب في ذلك
فلسطيني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا حساسيه الاسنان مشكله شائعه مره معجون
سنسداين المطور ترميم الحمايه الجديد
بيدخل لعمق السن وهذا بيساعد فانه يقلل من
حساسيه الاسنان امسح الاشخاص انهم ما
يهملوا مشكله حساسيه الاسنان
[موسيقى]
يد الام يا ما شاف الطول هالمشوار
ومع هذا لسه بتعرف كيف تختار حليب المراعي
الطازج الفرق بين الامهات
وفنانين
عن هجوم
سوريا والعراق
ارتفاع نسبه المصانع السعوديه الملتزمه
بتطبيق التصاريح البيئيه الى 77% خلال
العام الجاري
في مونديال قطر الجماهير العربيه تتواجد
لمسانده اسود الاطلس لتخطي فرنسا حملته
والدور الاوبرا السلطانيه في مسقط تحتفل
بعقدها الاول الرابعه في جوله خاص على
ابرز معالمها
اهلا بكم يلتقي معرض انا عربيه في منطقه
واجهه الرياض ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياضه
2022 بالزوار وسط مساحات المملوءه بابداع
المراه العربيه في التصاميم
الاحداث الترفيهيه النوعيه والراقيه ويعدو
اكبر تجمع في الشرق الاوسط يجمع المصممات
المبدعات في مكان واحد
[موسيقى]
بدنا فعاليات موسم الرياض احتضن معرض وانا
عربيه اكثر من 200 مصممه من مختلف الدول
العربيه
[موسيقى]
في التعريف عن نفسها وعن علامتها التجاريه
الجديده
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاركتي هنا هي بحد ذاتها تسويق
لمنتجاتنا لان المعرض مثل ما انت عارفه
جدا راقي جدا كلاس وعلى مستوى الوطن
العربي مش على مستوى الخليج فقط
بالنسبالنا هذا نجاح
يعني في مسيرتنا
[موسيقى]
ومن الازياء الى المجوهرات التي صممت
خصيصا للمعرض بقطع لا تتواجد على منصات
المصممات الالكترونيه كما كانت الاوائل
الفاخره زينه المعرض في مختلف ارجائه
[موسيقى]
شفت المعرض كثير حلو
بتجنن مثل العاده اهل السعوديه ما فينا
نحكي عليهم
قديش حبهم للتاوله والديكوريشن للطاوله
حتى اغراضي هون والحمد لله كل القبول كثير
حلو والمعرض كان كثير حلو
[موسيقى]
معرض وانا عربيه يجمع بين الفخامه والفن
والابداع ويتضمن ايضا فقرات موسيقيه
تعزفها فتيات عربيه اضافه الى عزف عود
يطرب زائري المعرض من الرياض شهد متروك
العربيه
كاس العالم
الاجواء هنا هادئه لان تركنا وسط الدوحه
قبل قليل مشرب وسوق واقف ونتجه الى استاد
مع انه المباراه ستقام بعد خمس ساعات
وخمسه عشر دقيقه ولكن السكيورتي او
الحراسه بسبب وصول
الرئيس الفرنسي ماكغون التي سيحضر هذه
المباراه ادى الى اغلاق الكثير من الطرق
هنا في الدوحه ولذلك ستكون المباراه يعني
حاميه الوطيس انا متاكد بين المغرب
المنتخب
الفرنسي وفي استاذ بيت الشعر البيت ستديوم
الذي ستقام على ارضه المباراه وهذا
الاستاذ طبعا خالد يتسع 68,000 و995 ايه
متفرج رقم هائل رقم كبير ولكن شاهدنا
الكثير من المغاربه اكثر بكثير من
المشجعين الفرنسيين الذين استقلوا همم
حافلات من وسط الدوحه متجهين نحو استديوم
او استاد همم
هنا شمال الدوحه الذي يقعد يقع في منطقه
همم سميسمه هنا في في قطر وسوف تكون يعني
التشجيع المغربي يكون اكبر بكثير وهذا
يلعب دور مهم للفريق او للمنتخب المغربي
اذكر تماما عندما ذكر همم المدرب المنتخب
همم
قال ان المشجعون هم اللاعب رقم 12 في
المباراه وهذا صحيح شاهدنا الكثير عندما
كان هناك تافات واحتفالات وتشجيع للفريق
يؤدي ذلك الى تسجيل اهداف هناك في مرمى او
المنتخب الذي يلعب معه المنتخب المغربي
يعطيك العافيه شكرا جزيلا لكم من الدول
الموسيقى في العاصمه العمانيه مسقط تتجلى
في ابها صورها عبر دور الاوبرا سلطانيه
التي تحتفل هذه الايام بمرور اكثر من عشر
سنوات على تدشينها هذه الدار تعتبر من
التحف المعماريه في الشرق الاوسط وتغنى
على مسرحها اشهر الموسيقيين العالميين
والعرب عبد الرحمن العصيمي في جوله في دار
الاوبرا السلطانيه
[موسيقى]
دار الاوبرا السلطانيه تحفه معماريه
تحتضنها العاصمه العمانيه مسقط مبناها
يتكون من ثمانيه طوابق منها ثلاثه تقع تحت
الارض وخمسه فوقها يتناغم تصميمها
المعماري مع التراث العماني والعربي
والاسلامي في عهود مختلفه وتقع على مساحه
تتجاوزوا 80 الف متر مربع
[موسيقى]
على هذا المسرح الذي يتسع لاكثر من الف
شخص عزف وتغني اشهر الفنانين العالميين
والعرب ابرزهم فنان العرب محمد عبده
القيصر كاظم الساهر امال ماهر وغيرهم
الكثير ومع احتفال دار الاوبرا السلطانيه
بمرور عشر سنوات على افتتاحها ينتظر
الجمهور في السلطنه باقه من العروض
والحفلات خلال الفتره الملكيه
[موسيقى]
دار الاوبرا السلطانيه تضم اكثر من 50
محلا تجاريا ما بين مقاهي ومطاعم
ومتاجر
تتنوعوا انشطتها ومجالاتها
اضافه مختلفه
لتجربه الزائر
[موسيقى]
والمجوهرات وغيرها من ابرز مبيعات محل
الاوبرا جاليريا الذي ياتي على شكل رواق
يداخم مبنى دار الاوبرا السلطانيه
الله
احب هذا المكان جدا لانه مميز وانصح دائما
السياحه بزياره هذا المكان المطاعم
والمقاهم هنا تعكس ثقافه وتاريخ السلطنه
يجب على اي شخص يزور مسقط ان ياتي الى
الاوبرا السلطانيه
يعتبر من المباني متعدده الاستخدامات حيث
يمكنه ان يستضيف فعاليات مختلفه كحفلات
الاوبرا والحفلات الموسيقيه والمسرحيه الى
جانب المؤتمرات والعديد من المتقيات
الثقافيه والفنيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
العاصمه العمانيه مسقط العربيه
[موسيقى]
علاقه المسلمين بالشمس والقمر والنجوم
علاقه الاستدلاليه فمن يستدلون على مواقيت
الصلاه واتجاه القبله وبدايه الشغل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والنجوم علاقه
استدلاليه فهم يعرفون بدايه شهورهم عن
طريق منازل القمر ويعرفون مواقيت صلاتهم
وقبلتهم عن طريق مواقع الشمس بالنهار وعن
طريق مواقع النجوم بالليل ومكان وزمان
شروق وغروب الشمس يتغير بشكل يومي طوال
ايام السنه يحصل احيانا ان تقطع الشمس
الخط الواصل بين المكان الى مكه ويشتغل في
تحديد القبله وعلماء العالم الاسلامي هم
اول من استخدم هذه الطريقه في تحديد
القبله دخل المحرمون الله يستغفرونه بمكه
شو مثلا وانا
يا رحمن واول سالتي لنفسه ليله ثم انت
حسيبها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يوم 15 ديسمبر تغرب الشمس باتجاه القبله
هل الرياض يوم 13 ديسمبر تغرب الشمس
باتجاه القبله على المنامه ويوم خمسه
فبراير تغرب الشمس باتجاه القبله على
الدوحه ويوم 24 فبراير تغرب الشمس في
اتجاه القبله على ابو ظبي ويوم 12 اكتوبر
تغرب الشمس باتجاه القبله على مسقط وهنالك
يومين في السنه تكون الشمس هي القبله وقت
اذان الظهر على الحرم على مستوى العالم
يوم 27 مايو ويوم 26 يوليو فلا اقسم برب
المشارق والمغارب انا لقادرون على ان نبدل
خيرا منه وما نحن
المسبوقين
[موسيقى]
ايران
هجوم
سوريا والعراق
تفاعل نسبه المصانع السعوديه الملتزمه
بتطبيق التصاريف البيئيه الى
77% خلال العام الجاري
في مونديال قطر والجماهير العربيه تتوافد
لمسانده اسود الاطلس لتخطي فرنسا
في جوله خاصه على ابرز المعالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]